haben wir den gut dabei nein wir haben
den nicht ich habe den wie
immer
ja hallo herzlich willkommen zur
Weinprobe im L mit bringen mir den Fusel
nie
[Gelächter]
weiter Hochzeitstag geschenkt dass wir
auch mal rauskommen 10 JR ja le und wie
lange m
noch ja W vielleicht vorher ein
schnapsrinker so gewissermaßen nees
Grundlage ja warum eigentlich
nein
nein ja ich habe auch noch den
Gutschein eine Weinprobe für zwei
Personen inklusive jo waschels original
französischer
gasplatte in was für Museum hab den
mitgelassen es ist do inzwischen wieder
15 Jahre her unser Z Hochzeitstag ja n
Reichsmark oder na jetzt machen wir so
jetzt K Inflationsausgleich drauf dann
passt es schon S wir mal vielleicht so
280 was soll der Geiz ma wir 300 €
geradeus
3€ der war
gut jetzt sind wir schon hergefahren
jetzt machen wir das auch die Kinder
freuen sich
über was dass mir eine ganz auf dem
Kopfen jetzt fang
R da nein danke ich habe kein ich habe
draußen vom Chateau rotchüler einen
ordentlichen Schluck eer R a
woher ist denn der Wein von unten aus
dem Keller direkt neben de renest die
haben gerade junge die so süß soll ich
die malaubringen oh
ja so
süß draußen und was ist jetzt das für
einer das ist einun riesing aus
un a eherer
b ja dann schauen wir
mal was machst du jetzt da
genauchaftel was sonst nein das macht
man so das habe ich im Fernsehen gesehen
beim Lafer Lichter
lecker
haben die auch sein Gesicht
gemacht also wenn ich jetzt sagen würde
der der ist herzhaft im B dann würde ich
lügen der ist eh geschissen im Abgang se
nicht so
ordinär gräuslig warer halt gruslig KUS
blo weißt du nicht W wie man Wein
verkostet freilich weiß ich das vom
Lafer und Lichter der Lafer und der
Lichter die wissen ein Scheißdreck und
der lecker war n der lecker ist
überhaupt PL von den drei teppen jetzt
pass auf mal wie man Wein verkostet
jetzt schau mal hier seh Schenk den Wein
ein so und dann jetzt pass
auf
exzellent
viel besser viel viel besser ja und an
was erinnert euch der Tropfen dass ich
viel lieber weißbi trink und zwar viele
Tropfen bist du ein Poet musst du immer
so einen blödsin reden das pas schon ich
mag das wen ein Mensch seine eigene
Meinung hat ja sagen m das heute nicht
aber wenn der
fein Ries vielleicht ein roten da hab
wir nämlich ein ganzen guten roten der
ist sehr trocken ganzer trocken Rotwein
ist
das ich nicht gagt ganz tr
wi verkung B überhaupt irgendjemand
drüber
lacht jetzt richtigen
Rotwein das W
ein das ist ein schrabverschluss ja sag
he gleich das hät du wirklich auch
gleich sagen können doch ein pel runter
das ist jetzt der ING so wie
Wein für mich riecht überhaupt nicht
nach ingwa ja freil nicht weiß das
wichtigste vergessen hast was hast den
vergessenin einmal plups und plups so
für den drucken ist der ganz schön
[Gelächter]
aus und
und also dann kommen wir zur original
französischen kplatte genau die
originalfanzösische kplatte vom lekack
dann gibt jetzt wenigstens was zu
essen nein s die ratzen ins hir
geschissen was hätte ich machen soll der
französische t war geschimmelt weiß ein
sünteurer französischer Schimmelkäse ist
darin ja kom wirklich nie recht
ma jetzt geht di wieder los Sir ist
dreckterag so jetzt hab Weinprobe wie
bestellt so
geliefert mir reicht auf den Gutschein
geh mal geh weiter ja ja los Weg
hier seind jetzt weg ja die se Weg die
ganz gut gemacht das soll wieder Leid
gibt die die die dass man gut sch
einlösen
kan ფi
[Musik]
H